[Music]
why do people get Alzheimer's how do you
differentiate amongst the different
types and and what's really going on
with imaging now we can see the
accumulation of certain toxic proteins
in people's brains there's general
consensus that there are a number of
these that are implicated in the disease
a beta or beta amyloid tau alpha
synuclein and others right I would say
those are the three primary culprits now
there are people that argue that it's
all microbiome based and there are
people that argue that it's a hundred
percent diet and exercise based on
related to the microbiome and there are
people that have a whole variety of
approaches to this none of which I I
believe are accredited or discredited in
a conclusive way I that's one of the
main reasons why I focus on this
ecosystem and this and this village that
it takes to solve these problems I don't
think this is a silver bullet disease I
think this is a this is a finding out
and unveiling and uncovering the the
different pieces that define it and and
you know just very very recently we
could an image for a maeda or beta
amyloid so there was no way to know that
very recently we couldn't there are new
serum based biomarkers that are coming
along to measure tau levels and that
that are really really interesting um
all of this gives us insight into the
accumulation and the timing of the
accumulation of these toxic proteins so
so I don't know you know the the one to
three biological assessment this is the
analogy that I always use imagine you go
into a sports bar there's a low guide
with glasses and he walks up to the
biggest guy in that place and the guys
just all steroid it up and he's got
veins popping out of his neck and he
walks up to the guy and he doesn't know
him he just pokes him right in the chest
there's going to be a cascade of events
caused by that poke maybe he'll get his
jaw broken maybe you'll have some ribs
cracked maybe he'll be thrown out of a
window maybe the cops will come maybe
they'll have to write up a police report
maybe they'll have to go to to a court
case after that all these things could
happen now depending on where you
that fight what started it you would
have no idea and all of your assessments
all your assumptions would be wrong if
you didn't see that guy unprovoked poke
that person in the chest so where is the
poke with Alzheimer's there's a lot of
debate around that but where that
cascade of events occurs there's
becoming more clarity around that so I
hope that's helpful if you look at it
from a disease progression state these
toxic proteins are building up in your
brain 10 15 20 years before you have any
symptoms so this is something that is is
laying there in a lot of us and just
waiting for its chance to jump up and so
so knowing that and having seen that in
in lots and lots of people the general
the general thought is that you have the
beta amyloid levels rising thereafter
you have the Tau levels rising
thereafter and and in consequence and in
concert with the tau level rising
there's some correlation with with the
actual cognitive impairment now that
doesn't mean that that's the biology of
Alzheimer's conclusively that means that
this is an evolving story and this ties
back into this village and ecosystem the
reason I'm so excited is because we
actually have answers to some of these
questions now so at least we know that
these are you know toxic or misfolded or
or in some way non non not advantageous
proteins right so we're starting to
understand that and being able to see it
and track it track its growth intervene
earlier all of those things are really
compelling so so the goal is to create
endo bodies naturally that go in that
they cross the blood-brain barrier and
engage the toxic forms of a beta plaque
and the way that I think about it is
like this you know a beta is naturally
occurring in everyone okay beta amyloid
is made by everywhere every person's
body it's when it starts to get stuck
together that it becomes a problem so
first two of them get stuck together
it's a dimer
then a bunch of get stuck together it's
an oligomers then a bunch of those get
stuck together to fib roll
then a bunch of those get stuck together
too plaque so once by the time it gets
to be a plaque it's it's a toxic it's a
toxic form of that of that protein so
what I'm excited about is that I believe
that we can target safely and
effectively the toxic forms of that miss
aggregated protein or that aggregated
protein and remove them safely we turn
on the body's ability to generate
antibodies the endo bodies that we
generate with our lead compound are
against the a beta targets and so so why
are we doing that at U n s or at United
Neuroscience a United neuroscience we're
activating the body's immune system to
target toxic proteins in the case of our
lead compound it's against beta amyloid
what happens is that the body identifies
these toxic forms only the toxic forms
so it's highly specific or primarily the
toxic forms and and binds to them in the
brain and removes them my audacious my
audacious goal for my team is that you
know if you can go early enough and your
product is safe enough there's
absolutely opportunities to prevent the
accumulation of these proteins in the
very first place so before there are
symptoms before there are any of those
things we vaccinate 500 million things a
year for less than a dollar a dose with
over 70% margins okay if you think about
now obviously human there's slightly
different CMC and different
manufacturing but the bottom line is
that technology platform is going to be
accessible and it's going to be
available for every one of the millions
of people that are suffering from this
disease and it's going to be able to
solve these problems potentially in in
ways that we envision to be or be a part
of a solution for these problems in ways
that we really envision to be beneficial
for society for people and for their
families and and and for what we're you
know for this global impact idea you
know what what could be a better way to
wake up and spend your time than really
being able to
to change people's lives and make them
better so that's that's kind of the
biology wrapped in a wrapped in a in a
in a nut you know
[Music]
you